today on the Matt wall show BLM chooses
its latest martyr but things don't work
out as they expect when his female
victim shows up at the protest to speak
out also the CEO of Starbucks shuts down
stores in a number of major cities
declaring that America is now unsafe but
is America unsafe or is it specifically
democrat-controlled cities that are
unsafe and also Democrats declare that
quote we're all going to die direct
quote after their latest global warming
Bill fails to pass plus Marvel fans call
for a trigger warning before the the new
Thor movie that just came out and our
daily cancellation the New York Times
has a report about hotness
not the global warming kind but the
other kind we'll talk about all that and
much more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the latest inflation numbers are in and
it's not looking good to say the least
we've hit a 40-year high at 9.1 percent
thanks to uh this genius brilliant
Administration our nation's authorities
are now openly admitting to having
completely missed the flashing red
lights of inflation and this
administration's failed Economic Policy
as well uh treasury secretary Janet
Yellen admitted she was wrong about the
path inflation would take saying quote
there have been unanticipated and large
shocks to the economy that have boosted
energy and food prices and Supply
bottlenecks that have affected our
economy badly that at the time I didn't
fully understand well there you have it
straight from the horse's mouth I didn't
fully understand I didn't anticipate you
says now I know you're worried about uh
affording basic necessities in the
months to come
food gas shelter but she didn't know
it's not her fault you know look guys
just take it easy on her goes without
saying that you can't trust the
so-called authorities on economic policy
which is why you should invest at least
some of your money in gold and silver
with Birch gold group protect your
savings from a highly turbulent economy
by diversifying your 401k or IRA into
physical gold it's not too late for you
to take action Now text Walsh to 989-898
and get a free info kit on diversifying
and protecting your savings with
precious metals Birch gold group has an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau countless five star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers for a
reason to find out why text Walsh to
989898 and get real advice from Birch
gold today again text Walsh to 989898 to
claim your free no obligation info kit
on protecting your savings with gold
so we've heard that the good guy with a
gun is a mythological figure a false
narrative such a person doesn't exist in
real life we're told or so the gun
grabbing faction claims anyway in the
case of Vivaldi they're correct we now
know according to the latest report
which came out just over the weekend
that 400 officers 400 not a typo
apparently were on the scene while the
shooter was executing elementary school
children this is a small army of heavily
armed cops
um not one good guy with a gun among
them though because they were all
worthless spineless quaking little
cowards but just because good guys with
guns don't exist in Uvalde Texas
apparently doesn't mean that they don't
exist anywhere else in the country like
in Indiana for example as CNN reports
quote a shooting rampage that killed
three people and injured two others at
an Indiana Mall ended after an armed
witness shot and killed the assailant
police said around 6 PM local time
Sunday multiple people called 911 report
an active shooter at the Greenwood Park
Mall Greenwood police a chief Jim Isen
told reporters investigators believe the
unidentified gunmen and adult male was
shot and killed by a lawfully armed 22
year old man who quote observed the
shooting in progress according to Ison
the Greenwood police department has
trained for a mass shooting scenario and
has performed multiple Mall exercises to
prepare for active shooter situations he
said quote but I'm going to tell you the
real hero of the day is the citizen that
was lawfully carrying a firearm in the
food court and was able to stop the
shooter almost as soon as he began Eisen
said but this is a CNN article which
means that there's going to be some
narrative damage control done also so
immediately after that we're also told
it's rare to have an armed bystander
attack an active shooter according to a
data analysis published by the New York
Times there were at least 433 active
shooter attacks in the US from 2000 2021
according to the data anal analysis
active shooter attacks were defined as
those in which one or more Shooters
killed or attempted to kill multiple
unrelated people in a populated place of
those 433 active shooter cases and armed
bystanders shot the attacker in 22 of
the incidents in 10 of those the good
guy was a security guard or an off-duty
police officer the times reported and
having more than one armed person at the
scene who is not a member of law
enforcement can create confusion and
carry dire risks the report found
now of course the statistics that are
presented here uh they're presented in
such a way to immediately disqualify
dozens or even hundreds of other good
guy with a gun scenarios they're only
counting so-called active Shooters
dispatched by armed bystanders and then
they and then they qualify that and
Define that in a very arbitrary way so
they aren't counting incidents like the
one that occurred just two days ago in
St Louis where a customer at a gas
station shot and killed an armed robber
who was in the middle of a violent crime
spree the guy had a knife to the throat
of the uh of of the the cashier
that sort of thing happens frequently
but all such events are magically erased
through tricks of categorization
and yet even as CNN presents it
let's just pretend it's only 22. that's
22 Mass Shooters in the last 22 years
who have been taken down by armed
bystanders that likely means hundreds of
lives saved
at least once a year by CNN's estimate a
mass shooting is thwarted by a good guy
with a gun
this would seem to be very positive news
and reason enough to encourage Law
Abiding and responsible gun owners to
exercise their second amendment rights
as much as possible but as we've learned
there could be no positive news if it
contradicts The Narrative that's why the
reaction to this story on the left has
drifted all the way into outright
Sympathy for the dead Mass shooter one
viral tweet from a CBS reporter in
Indiana can I think summarize this
sentiment pretty well Justin Kohler
tweeted the term Good Samaritan came
from a Bible passage of a man from
Samaria who stopped on the side of the
road to help a man who was injured and
ignored I cannot believe we live in a
world where the term can equally apply
to someone killing someone my God
yes he killed someone what a shameful
tragedy never mind that the someone in
this case was a mass murdering
psychopath that the bystander risked his
life for the sake of rescuing strangers
from these Psychopaths bloody Rampage
that's not enough to earn the Good
Samaritan badge says Justin and many on
the left have voiced their agreement
with that
but this was not the weekend's only
example of the left sympathizing with a
crazed lunatic gunman there was another
far more egregious case a case that
brings us yet another name to add to the
Rogues gallery of BLM martyrs on Friday
ambulance chasing parasite Ben chump or
Crump sorry a race-baiting vulture so
totally devoid of Integrity that Al
Sharpton looks like Frederick Douglass
by comparison tweeted the following
quote this is techel Sundberg
Minneapolis the police department killed
this smart loving and artistic 20 year
old after an hours-long standoff while
he was experiencing a mental health
crisis we need answers from MPD as to
why techel's Mental Health crisis became
a death sentence exclamation point
he chooses an accompanying photo of a
good old teckel smiling warmly and
innocently he apparently decided not to
post a photo like this one which you can
see where sunberg can be seen holding a
giant bag of weed and pointing Two
Pistols at the camera two pistols in one
hand by the way not good gun safety just
so you know credit to crump though for
managing to find an image of this guy
where he's not waving a firearm around
that couldn't have been easy though on
second thought his hands are cut off in
the picture Crump chose they're cropped
out of the photo so we have no idea what
he might have been holding actually
but we do know what he was holding on
the night when police shot and killed
him uh he was armed and had been in a
standoff as actually Crump noted with
police for over six hours so they tried
for six hours to coax him out of the
apartment building where he had
barricaded himself finally a police
sniper had a shot and took it judging
that he posed an intolerable danger to
other people in the building and they
had reason to make that assumption
because sunberg had been firing
indiscriminately into a neighboring
apartment where a young mother and her
children were present and were cowering
in fear hiding for their lives
this is the loving and artistic man that
Crump calls for us to mourn
and BLM activists in the city were of
course eager to heed the call a crowd
gathered outside of the scene of the
shooting a couple of days later on
Saturday to Lament The Death of The
Psychotic man who attempted to uh you
know Murder a woman and her children
and also to protest the police who saved
the lives of that woman and her children
how dare they
the protesters marched and they held
their signs and they chanted in support
of their new scumbag hero everything was
going according to plan as we've seen
many times before
until a woman named Arabella Foss
Yarbrough uh threw a wrench in their
plants
she's the woman whose apartment sunberg
was firing into
and she of course is not at all the
first female victim of a BLM martyr far
from it nearly every BLM martyr has had
a history of violently abusing women
which is not a coincidence by the way
but she is the first as far as I know to
show up and speak out publicly
she confronted the crowd
about what she experienced and about
what their martyr what their hero had
done to her and her children
and their response to her speaks volumes
listen to this
[Music]
[Music]
silence situation
he was unarmed you're alive I'm sorry
this is not okay
kids have to deal with this and probably
have a mental illness now because they
almost lost their life
still holds in my kitchen why
watching my move
I wish it never happened
place to call home
she's obviously going through a moment
this is not okay this is what they want
to show on the TV it's obviously
he tried to kill me
[Applause]
you're alive someone in the crowd
sarcastically responds she's obviously
going through a moment says a guy with a
plethora of chins
someone else is more direct shut up
he said to her
shut up
I mean this is a woman saying you know
this guy was shooting into my apartment
with my kids and almost killed me shut
up
the crowd of what appears to be mostly
middle-aged white people openly scoffs
at a young woman who lived through a
night of Terror as she and her children
were forced to dodge bullets in their
own home
a home that can't go back to she knows
because it's riddled with bullet holes
the crowd of BLM Boomers wanted to
dismiss and silence the victim of their
new hero
that's what they wanted to do but they
didn't succeed because the video went
viral and just like that
as soon as that video went viral
the media moved on from the sunberg
story just moved on
like it never happened
all future plans for murals and
monuments and statues have all
presumably been canceled
arabella's testimony was such an
embarrassment for BLM and that scene you
just watched such a humiliation for them
that they have no choice but to pretend
the whole thing never happened
riots are called off everything's called
off
we'll wait for the next one okay we'll
wait for a BLM martyr who victimized
women but um where the women are not
going to say anything publicly
even Ben chump uh or Crump hasn't spoken
out about it again since Friday
instead he's moved on you know the
latest thing I checked actually I
checked right before I went on the air
to see if he has offered any updates on
this story of course I knew that he
wasn't going to retract or apologize
obviously but I want to see what he was
talking about well he's moved on now to
tweeting angrily about two black girls
who are allegedly snubbed by a racist
Sesame Street character at a parade
that's what he's moved on to he said
never mind this uh sunberg thing let's
talk about the parade let's make that
into a thing
and I'll assume he'll ride that horse
until uh you know the Sesame Street
character speaks out with his side of
the story
in the end it makes you wonder really
what might have happened had Jacob
Blake's rape victim um or the victim of
George Floyd's home invasion robbery
spoken up
now one can certainly understand why
they didn't it takes immense courage to
speak up when the mob wants you to stay
silent
but fortunately Arabella had that
courage
and she exposed BLM for what it is
and what it's always been
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know today's world is a pretty scary
one too many people don't seem to care
about the truth moral standards have
flown out the window and I'd argue that
all that is rooted in people I.E the
left becoming less rather I would say
anti-religious that's why it's more
important than ever that we take a step
back from all this craziness and keep
our relationships with God strong the
best way to do that is by praying every
day with hallow hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S it's
like calm or headspace but rooted in
Catholic faith as opposed to the
religion of leftism hallow offers over 5
000 audio guided prayers of meditation
as well Christian music tracks They got
a lot of stuff there some of the most
popular prayers include the Bible and a
year with father Mike Schmitz minute
meditations and meditations for sleep as
well hallow helps me find uh peace and
calm throughout the day every day even
as crazy leftists yell at me through a
tiny screen it helps me sleep better
also lowers my anxiety levels and helps
me teach my kids not to be terrible
humans which is an important lesson for
all kids let Halo help you find your
peace and strength and also help you
strengthen your faith today go to
hallow.com Matt walsher text pray to
1-855-944-5684 and get an extended three
month free trial during which you'll
have access to all five thousand
meditations and prayers that's hello.com
Matt Walsh or text pray to
1-855-944-5684 for three months free
reclaim your piece in this crazy world
download hello today
well we start with some familiar
unfortunately familiar scenes around the
country first here's Malibu where a gang
of looters carried off about a half a
million dollars of uh
items you can see it here so they're
just
you know they're running but they're
being relatively casual some of them are
wearing masks others aren't even
bothering to but why bother wear masks
you're not gonna be prosecuted
and they take us about half a million uh
items they took from this luxury you
know boutique store and ran off
and that's in Malibu and we had another
case this was in San Francisco it's on
the exact same day and here we have a
group of thugs just uh smashing now
they're being very casual about it
because this is San Francisco you don't
have to worry about it nothing's going
to happen to you at all you take all the
time you want guys and they smash the
windows of this van
and are taking everything they can out
of it and then just driving off doesn't
matter they're driving up someone well
as they drive off someone runs up and
kicks the car as it's driving away so
that's that's all we're getting for law
enforcement that's as far as the law
enforcement efforts are going to go in
San Francisco the looters as they're
driving away in their vehicle someone
runs up it just kicks the tires hey get
out of here don't come back
and then that's not it either because
the next incident also happened a couple
days ago around the same time this is a
restaurant I'm not sure where this is
but you can see two people
just walking behind the counter
and carrying off a whole tray of fried
chicken what are they going to do with
all that fried chicken I mean that's way
too much for one person to eat but hey
why not just take it she's got some uh
containers look like some biscuits in
there
just walking off with it because this is
what you can do
and those are just from the last couple
of days
as we know we've seen footage like this
from cities across the country every
single day it's bad enough now that
major chains are abandoning these places
all together they're shutting down we've
seen this already Target Walgreens CVS
other you know chains like that and some
of these cities have shut down now
Starbucks is the latest here's the CNN
report it says Starbucks is planning to
close 16 locations across various cities
citing safety concerns
um a spokesperson told CNN business
quote after careful consideration we're
closing some stores and locations that
have experienced a high volume of
challenging incidents so that's the
euphemism we're going with here these
are challenging incidents
um that make it unsafe to continue to
operate the stores are in Seattle Los
Angeles Philadelphia Washington DC and
Portland Oregon
they'll be organ they'll be closed by
the end of July just a side note here
I'm I'm stopping to think what do all
those places have in common
Seattle Los Angeles Philadelphia
Washington Portland
might be some some common threads some
similarities you know when you do the
Venn diagram you might find a lot of
some some things that that fall into
that middle bubble there
continues in a Monday letter to
employees Debbie Stroud and Denise
Nelson both senior vice presidents of
U.S operations discussed safety in
Starbucks stores said employees are
seeing firsthand the challenges facing
our communities personal safety racism
lack of Access to Health Care a growing
Mental Health crisis Rising drug use and
more with stores and thousands of
communities across the country we know
these challenges can at times play out
within our stores too
um
and so they're shutting down the stores
now they throw in racism because they
got to put something in there that's PC
I'm surprised they didn't they didn't
also include climate change given where
some of these things are happening and
they're in some warmer climates they
could have just chalked the whole thing
up they said you know we got to get out
of town because the climate change is
getting too much we got to move Inland
Higher Ground
uh last week Howard Schultz who's the
CEO of uh Starbucks had an internal
meeting with his executive team and the
video was released I don't know if it
was leaked or what but it ended up
online and here's what he said this is
kind of instructive listen to this
I don't have to spend too much time on
what's going on in the country and how
America has become unsafe
but you all read the press release the
last couple days about the fact that we
are beginning to close stores that are
not unprofitable
but we're closing stores as a result of
the co-creation sessions that we've had
almost 60 now 25 in the soc and the rest
in the field we had one yesterday in San
Antonio but in all of those sessions
uh
it has shocked me that one of the
primary concerns that our Retail
Partners have
is their own personal safety
and then we heard the stories that go
along with it about what happens in our
bathrooms
the issue of mental illness the issues
of homelessness and the issues of crime
and Starbucks is a window into America
we have stores in every community and we
are facing things in which the Sorrows
were not built for
and so we're listening to our people and
closing stores and this is just the
beginning there are going to be many
more
Okay so
a couple of couple things there from
what he says first of all
you know he says America America is
unsafe America is unsafe but you notice
he's not leaving Starbucks is not
leaving America they're just leaving
certain places in America they're
leaving Seattle and Portland and uh like
I said those places Los Angeles
Philadelphia Washington D.C
and he chalks that up to America has
become unsafe
um it's not you know this is not an
America problem
America is not an unsafe place
there are certain areas in America which
are extremely unsafe
and which I certainly wouldn't be
starting any businesses and I wouldn't
be moving to them
but that's not America as a whole
because non-urban areas that are not run
by democrats
have not seen
any well in most cases any sizeable or a
crime Spike or any crime Spike at all
where I am right now you know where I've
spent the last few weeks it's a small
town America far away from the nearest
big city and uh people still leave their
doors unlocked that night when they go
to sleep nobody worries about it
people leave their keys in their car you
know you can go to the local convenience
store and the cashier isn't hiding
behind bulletproof glass you know in
fact I went into the tackle shop nearby
a couple days ago and the guy working
there had to run in the back for
something he left the cash register
unattended for several minutes
Unthinkable in many of these places
and yet that's what happens around here
and in mil and and in many areas in in
this country
but those again are non-urban not
Democrat not Democrat controlled
places
that don't have this problem
so why is that
like why don't they have the problem
here but they have it in Los Angeles and
they have it in Seattle and they have it
in Philadelphia they have it in
Washington DC
well one is weak leadership okay that's
that's not a surprise
um a leadership that refuses
to actually pursue these criminals and
punish them
it's a it's a very strange connection
here where if you if you don't punish
certain activity certain Behavior then
you get more of that behavior
if you don't do anything to stop it you
get more of it and that's true on a
small scale with parents of young kids
and that's also true on a societal level
as well if Society does not punish
violent
intolerable unacceptable Behavior you
get more of it
there's no disincentive
you know you can't uh despite the
utopian hopes of of some people you you
can't just hope on people's everyone to
have a you know be good-hearted and
good-natured and
and make their own decision to to not
behave this way
so when you have leadership that is weak
you end up with more of this
and then also it's a matter of of
culture
collapse of the family
okay the still unspeakable reality in
these situations but that is a reality
we have to talk about is that crime is a
whole lot worse than predominantly black
areas it just is that's that's a fact I
mean that's just an absolute fact cannot
be disputed
why is that well because the family in
the black community is totally ravaged
destroyed
and in fact there are predominantly
white areas that have horrible crime
problems as well if you go to really
poor areas in Appalachia you go to
trailer parks that are uh that are just
drug addiction meth addiction is ravaged
those places too but what do you find
there you also find that the family it
hardly exists
you find a lot of single parents and you
find a lot of kids that are raised
essentially with no parents at all they
might have there might be a warm body in
the home that takes the takes the title
of parent but isn't actually doing
anything to pair the kids because the
parent is is a drug addict and that's
all they're worried about
so that's the commonality here
and
now it's all it gets worse it spreads
Across America the more the family
collapses
and this is uh yes the the family the
state of the family the state of
marriage childless homes fatherless
homes that's the worst in the inner city
now there you're talking about 80 90
percent of kids raised without fathers
in the home uh but the number is going
up especially fatherless Homes single
parent homes is going up across the
country
and so the more that happens this is
going to become increasingly an American
problem
but right now
um you find it
by Far and Away predominantly in these
communities
because of leadership actually it's it's
you know it's it's not leadership and
something else it's actually just
leadership it's leadership in the city
and then it's also leadership in the
home so when you have a lack of
leadership of of political leadership
and you also have a lack of leadership
in the home
kids that are raised in homes where
there's no one leading them there's no
example set then you have total absolute
chaos
what else could you expect
all right let's go next
to this mediaite has this report it says
more Trump voters living in
republican-controlled States said
secession would make things better in
their states than those who said it
would not
respondents to a new Yahoo news you gov
poll were asked do you think your state
would be better off or worse off if it
left the United States became an
independent country among all
respondents more than twice as many said
they'd be worse off as those who said
things would be better off well 15
things would be about the same another
24 responded they were not sure but
Yahoo News West Coast correspondent
Andrew Romano broke down the responses
to a more granular level and found
people in red states who voted for
former president Donald Trump were much
more amenable to seceding
quote Red State Donald Trump voters are
now more likely to say they'd be
personally better off at 33 than worse
off at 29 if their state seceded from
the U.S and became an independent
country
it's a striking rejection of national
Unity that dramatizes the growing
culture war between Democratic and
republican-controlled States on core
issues such as guns abortion and
democracy itself uh Etc and so forth now
just a note I want to make about that
that
um
the people responding that they think
their life would be
we can assume they mean in the immediate
better
you know if if there was a national
divorce I think those people are um they
they are utopianists in their own right
because that's not the case
I mean history is a pretty good guide
here both American history and the
history of the world
that when a country breaks apart
uh whether it's through a civil war or
not
and it's pretty rare that you have the
you know a country breaking apart
peacefully in fact I don't think it's
ever happened
at least it's again it's very rare
um but no matter how it happens
people's lives are not immediately
better in fact your your lives get worse
in the immediate and that would be the
case here too
there are a whole lot of reasons for
that
one is just a simple fact when you have
a seismic change of this kind
um it's not going to make things better
immediately
this is further destabilization
and there are a lot of problems too
especially for if you imagine some sort
of scenario where things break apart
from Red states to Blue States and it's
hard to even imagine how that would work
because uh it's not like 1861 where the
split was kind of right across the
middle you cut the country in half
that's not the case here you know red
States and blue states are kind of
intermingled and then you have uh you've
you've thoroughly blue areas within red
States how does all that work
just more indication of why you know
breaking a part of the country would not
be peaceful
because things would need to realign in
a way that just probably could not be
done peacefully probably
and then there are problems too if
you're if you end up in the the however
this breaks up however this this ends up
getting organized
if you're on the if you're in the red
State portion
um a lot of let's just look at the fact
that a lot of the uh the majority of the
manufacturing in this country happens in
blue States like California
um not to mention Silicon Valley you
know all the the people that control the
internet are all going to be now in a
different country that's hostile to your
own
so a lot of problems
uh and and yet you might you hear me say
this and you might be thinking well
haven't you said that you think a
national divorce is the way forward what
I'm saying is that I think we're going
to reach a point
where there's no other choice
it's not ideal of course it's not ideal
the ideal scenario the best case
scenario for everybody
is that the people in this country
who've lost their minds and are now
living in a separate universe that they
come to their senses collectively and
rejoin us
in in reality
where they live a life grounded to some
extent in truth and moral decency and we
can all unite there in that place and
move forward together as a country
that's the best that's ideal that's what
I would Far and Away prefer
it's just that it's that's probably not
going to happen you want to talk about
things that have never happened in
history I don't think anything like
that's ever happened
where you have divisions that are this
deep and this wide and they just kind of
on their own mend themselves
I don't think that's ever happened to
pray for that pray for that to happen
every day I just don't think it will
so I think we're going to reach a point
where there's simply No Way Forward when
you have two
sides
and even on those sides they break into
smaller sides and everything is
factionalizing but you still have this
Rift right down the middle of of two
sides living in separate universes for
how long can they share a country
I think you're going to reach a point
where it simply cannot go on
and um
what happens from there in the immediate
is not good or fun and it's going to be
it would be very difficult to say the
least
but again I'm I try to be
to stay in reality that's where I like
to live and this is the reality
I just think we don't we don't want to
romanticize it or have um
you know have have hopes that are
unfounded
all right let's move to this it says um
let's see speaking of living in
different universes pretty good example
here nj.com it says a transgender inmate
who impregnated two women while
incarcerated at Edna Mahan correctional
facility for women has been moved to a
new facility according to the Department
of Corrections Demi minor 27 was
transferred to Garden State youth
correctional facility a prison for young
adult offenders in Burlington County
um he said the this is according to Dan
sperraza Department of Corrections
spokesman he said the doc moved minor to
the vulnerable unit at the facility and
that she's currently the only she is
currently the only woman prisoner on the
site
browser said he could not comment on the
doc specific housing actions in miners
case because of policies around privacy
so this is a
I feel like this should be making even
bigger headlines than it is
actually not making that many headlines
because because the the mainstream media
would rather not talk about something
like this
um but this this is big news I mean a
woman a woman impregnated two other
women that's never happened before in
history
by the way somehow some uh video of this
this this person Demi Moore has his own
Twitter account which I would like to
assume he's not running himself
but there are videos of him that have
that that get posted somehow so he has
apparently access to a cell phone
um maybe that's part of him living his
true identity he said you know what I'm
a woman who needs a cell phone so you
know us ladies we like to gaps you got
to give me a selfie they gave him a cell
phone and he's been posting videos and
um it's not going to surprise you to
learn that this guy is making no attempt
whatsoever to even appear like a woman
even if he was making an attempt
wouldn't make a difference doesn't mean
he should still be he should be housed
with with women
but that's the farce okay
that's happening in the prison system
right now
you've got these men
who are openly taking advantage
of this new situation where they could
be transferred to a woman's facility
and why would a man want to be
transferred to a woman facility Well I
don't think I need to explain that one
is that it's a lot safer for any man
trans or not
you know it's now there is violence that
happens at Women's uh prisons but you
got to think as a man you have to be a
little bit less concerned about some of
the things that can happen to you as a
man in a man's facility
so it's a cushier safer situation and
also you have if you're a violent
offender
you have access to a whole bunch of
women who are now going to be locked in
cages with you
and apparently this guy took advantage
of in two cases and and now they're two
women pregnant
on the same note here CNN ha I don't
know why I keep reading from CNN today
that's a that's a mistake but
that's where we are it says the
University of Pennsylvania nominated
swimmer Leah Thomas who's become the
face of the debate on transgender women
in sports for the 2020 for the 2022 NCAA
Woman of the Year award the ivy league
swimmer was nominated as a division one
athlete for swimming and Diving the
award is meant to honor the quote
academic achievements Athletics athletic
Excellence community service and
Leadership of graduating female college
athletes from all three divisions
so
the University of Pennsylvania
has heard
all of the outrage over Leah Thomas
being allowed to compete against women
heard the outrage from outside and also
from within from the actual real women
being forced to compete against this guy
being forced to share a locker room with
him
we heard from one of those uh swimmers
in my film what is a woman which you can
watch by going to what is a woman.com so
they've heard all of this and their
response is a big middle finger to
everybody saying you know what oh you
didn't like that you didn't you you
didn't like that well guess what uh now
we're nominating him for a woman of the
year how do you like that
because this for the umpteenth time is
what the left always does they always
Double Down
you could be outraged you could be upset
and their response is going to be oh you
didn't like that but now I'm going to do
more of the thing you're upset about
now is that an argument on our side for
giving up or for surrendering or for
soft pedaling even more so as we don't
upset them so there are a lot of
conservatives who seem to take that
approach
no it's it's an argument for doing the
exact same thing
they double down we triple down
that's the only way forward
I also wanted to mention this from NBC
News Democrats are sounding dire
warnings after Senator Joe manchin
tanked their hopes of acting on climate
change
here's a quote from chairman John
yarmuth who's the house budget committee
chairman he says we're all going to die
which is actually true we are all going
to die in fact but are we going to die
soon from climate change that I'm
skeptical about but this is what he's
saying we're all gonna die
yarmouth's remarks on Friday captured
the cocktail of anger frustration
resentment and powerlessness that many
Democrats felt after mansion took a
one-man wrecking ball to What's Left of
President Joe Biden's agenda dealing a
heavy blow to their big policy Ambitions
and further complicating a tough midterm
election landscape for the party
um and there were many other people
quoted Corey Bush among them but a lot
of Democrats in fact there was another
report
I think was also from CNN but I've read
too much CNN stuff of uh Democrats who
were and Democrat staffers who were in
tears over this distraught because as
Yarmouth said we're all gonna die now
because of Joe manchin
and we've been now it the good news is
that we were supposed to be dead already
and the apocalypse keeps getting moved
back and moved back we are repeatedly
informed that this is our last chance we
have to act right now if we don't it's
over
and we've been told that over and over
and over again over the last 20 years or
so
and we managed to survive
but maybe this is it for this time this
time it's real
because of Joe manchin we are all gonna
die the fate of the world is sealed
Joe manchin will go down as the man who
murdered seven billion people
CBS certainly seems to think so here's
their report on the um climate change
crisis and all the people that it's
killing especially in Europe listen to
this
the same Heat Wave is already being
blamed for extreme temperatures and
widespread wildfires across other parts
of Europe you're looking at the pictures
and scientists say this is all part of
climate change caused by human activity
Roxanna siberi is tracking Europe's hot
weather and the Damage it's causing
this is Raging across Southwest France
have scorched around 35
000 acres and forced more than 16
thousand people to fleece
spay in the scene seems similarly
apocalyptic
neighboring Portugal remains on high
alert after fires were fanned by drought
that's hit at least 96 percent of the
country and a heat wave reaching a
record of nearly 117 degrees he here and
in Spain authorities say more than 1 000
people have died from their recent Heat
and now Britain is bracing for its
threatened high of at least 103 degrees
on Tuesday so hot the UK's National
Weather Service has issued its first
ever red warning for extreme heat
meaning there's a risk to life
scientists say heat waves have become
more frequent and more intense and last
longer climate change has everything to
do with the extreme weather that we're
seeing at the moment and its human
induced climate change is not a natural
variation
you know as always such a narrow view of
history and uh and and giving human
beings a really elevated
status you know uh because keep in mind
every time we hear us record-breaking
Heat this is the hottest it's ever been
in this part of the world
that that always comes with a with a
certain qualification because sometimes
when they say record-breaking how does
everyone sometimes they mean uh in the
last 80 years sometimes I mean the last
100 years sometimes they go back 120 it
really depends on when they decide what
what record they're looking at and when
they've decided the Records begin
but whatever it is I can tell you that
the Earth is in fact older than 60 years
older than 80 it's even older than 120.
you might uh might find that shocking to
find out if in fact the Earth's been
around for billions of years
um and so whenever they say this is the
hottest that this part of the the world
has ever been you can know for for a
certainty that that's not the case
whatever you're experiencing right now
it's not the hottest it's not the
coldest it's not the worst
the Earth's been around for a long time
a very long time
and the idea that human beings I it's
just it's I'm sorry it's absurd on its
face
that this
planet
she's existed for billions of years
which is I constantly have to remind
people is um
is a slave not to our SUVs but to the
sun okay that giant enormous ball of gas
at the center of our solar system
which we are orbiting around okay which
has a a gravitational pull that that
stretches billions of miles out in the
space
um which could you know the the sun
could burp tomorrow
and incinerate all life on Earth all
right just with that have a the sun
could have a little bit of indigestion
and incinerate all life on Earth
and that's what's calling the shots as
far as the weather goes on Earth
but the notion that human beings it's
not even that that human beings since
the beginning of human civilization
which really you know when did when did
civilization begin you know maybe 10 000
years ago
um it's not even they're not even
claiming that that during that time
we have managed to destroy all life on
Earth and destroy the planet they're
saying just since industrialization
okay so really through the whole course
of Earth that's just the small sliver of
time
we have destroyed all life in her we
have that kind of power they say
and we also have the power to heal the
Earth and that we can do it through
legislation
and think about how to talk about narrow
okay legislation that if it impacts
anything it only impacts what the United
States does
forgetting about the entire rest of the
populated Earth
all of Asia for example
with with it has countries with billions
of people in it and these are
industrialized societies
well they can still do whatever they
want to do
but the Democrats in Congress they have
the power to just write legislation that
heals the planet and rescues us from
Doom
and yet in this case they were not able
to pass the legislation so we are doomed
for the 100th time we're doomed and can
I say if that's the I am highly
skeptical about that claim okay I'm very
skeptical about it but if it's true
if John if Joe manchin really doomed us
all at this time it's actually serious
this was our last best chance it's over
now then then okay then why worry we're
doomed anyway just live your life while
you have in in enjoy the warmer
temperatures to the extent that you can
go spend a lot of time at the pool at
the beach you're gonna have a lot more
of the beach as it comes you know as it
as it comes Inland more and more and uh
and just enjoy because it's nothing we
can do now according to you
why worry about the things you can't
change that's my question uh one of the
quick thing this is from the daily wires
is fans of the Marvel of uh the Marvel
films are divided about a chemotherapy
scene and the new hit film Thor love and
Thunder with some clamoring for a
trigger warning and others deriding the
protesters for their squeamishness uh
Thor love and thunder premiered on July
8th it features a scene in which actress
Natalie Portman who plays Thor's love
interest scientist Jane Foster undergoes
chemotherapy treatment for stage four
cancer
um one fan wrote on social media no
spoilers but Thor love and thunder
should have a trigger warning for
graphic depictions of cancer and the
fact that we didn't know going in is
atrocious
the fanuclided cancer is way too common
of a trigger and when they show it that
graphically with that much imagery and
dwelling on it and talking about it that
much you need to be warned especially
for a Marvel movie which people go to
for escapism and shouldn't have to read
the comics
um so I guess you got cancer in the
comics and that's why they have I don't
know and then there are other fans
chiming in saying this is terrible
people have PTSD from it
but this is actually interesting because
on one hand I I you know what I sort of
agree I I sort of agree with with the
criticism that it's gratuitous in a way
to put a cancer storyline into the
middle of one of these dumb movies into
the middle of Thor you know it's it is
it is a little bit actually gratuitous
um and the reason is that these aren't
real movies they're just toy commercials
and brand awareness campaigns and in
that context cancer seems like a kind of
inappropriate subject matter and sort of
exploitative now I don't think there
should be a trigger warning because I
Just Disagree in principle the trigger
warnings but it is a cheap and kind of
easy way to create an emotional moment
without doing the work as the left likes
to say you haven't done the work so it's
lazy you don't have to uh do you know
write a good script you don't have to
make people emotionally invested in the
scene you don't have to worry about good
acting all you have to do is just have a
character with cancer and and that's
good enough it's kind of like using a
Nazi as your bad guy which I think these
Marvel movies also do quite a bit
because if you do that
it's easy you don't have to actually
convince the audience through good
writing and good acting to hate the bad
guy he's a Nazi he's got all that
baggage with them all the work is done
just slap a you know slap a um yeah you
know a Nazi symbol on him and you're
good to go so
on one hand I agree on the other hand
Trigger warnings as a concept are
incredibly stupid
um so it just goes to show though that
Martin Scorsese was correct when he said
that Marvel movies aren't Cinema they're
more like theme parks
and in cinema you know the audience
would never be upset or offended because
something happened they didn't expect
like you that's what you want if you
actually are a film fan and you want to
go watch a movie if you want to partake
in the art of Cinema and and witness it
then you don't want to know every beat
ahead of time you want things to happen
that you don't expect that's why you're
there that's part of the magic of Cinema
but superhero fans
um that's not what they're in it for
they want the same thing over and over
again
uh very much like children they just
want the same thing over and over again
they don't want anything surprising
anything different they just want a
theme park ride where you see the track
ahead of time and you've been on it
before and you know where all the dips
and Dives and everything are going to be
so I guess in that way it's like an
actual theme park ride if they tried to
if you're on a theme park right there
was a a cancer theme park ride we would
all agree that's highly inappropriate so
in a way
I can actually see where they're coming
from
this was my attempt to sympathize with
marble fans while at the same time
insulting them which is the only way I
can do it
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
with summer vacation season now in full
swing it's important to protect yourself
from identity theft while you're
traveling which is a time when you're
pretty vulnerable to it one of the most
widespread risks to personal information
to watch out for is uh pickpocketing
with your credit cards social security
number driver's license in hand identity
thieves have all the info they need to
do what they do Best by using your
identity you think of identity theft if
something happens online which it does
but it can also happen in physical form
as well
um through uh through pickpocketing so
it's important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives every day your personal
information gets exposed so often making
it dangerously easy for someone to steal
your identity protecting your identity
has never been more important and never
been easier with LifeLock by Norton
LifeLock detects and alerts you to
potential identity threats that you may
not be able to spot on your own and if
you do become a victim of identity theft
God forbid a dedicated us-based
restoration specialist will work to fix
it for you nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions in all businesses but it's
easy to help protect yourself with
Lifelock Identity Theft Protection
Starts Here join now and save up to 25
off your first year at lifelock.com
Walsh that's lifelock.com Walsh for 25
off
okay first comment says
my daughter was born without a uterus
and even then it proves she's a woman
because she has to have medical
interventions because of it men don't
need medical intervention if they don't
have uterus yes that's a very good point
and uh it's a point I made before this
is what we call the exception that
proves the rule in that
you know to the people who say well you
can't Define a woman as someone with a
uterus or someone who can get pregnant
because there are women who can't get
pregnant or don't have uteruses well
this is a section that proves the rule
because if a woman you know is not able
is is of child bearing age and is not
able to get pregnant then you know that
something's wrong like you that you
could go to the doctor as a woman and
say this is the issue I can't get
pregnant and the doctor is going to know
something is wrong here okay and it
might not be that you don't have a
uterus it could be anything it could be
dozens of different things hundreds of
different things but they know that
something is going wrong and most of the
time they if they run some tests and
they take a look they can find out what
it is like sure enough you're coming to
me as a woman you say you can't get
pregnant well we know that women should
be able to get pregnant because that is
one of the defining features of a woman
the fact that you are not able to means
that something is wrong let's take a
look sure enough
so here it is here's here's the problem
could be a hormonal problem it could be
a problem uh with you know it could be a
problem with the reproductive organs it
could be anything
whereas for a man right if if you go to
the doctor and say I'm not able to get
pregnant well that is not an indication
that anything is wrong at all they could
run all the tests in the world and they
could find that everything isn't
perfectly working order because men are
not supposed to be able to get pregnant
and no man ever has
so good point there thanks for bringing
that up uh future imperfect says got to
disagree there Matt cultural
appropriation is levied at other races
Aquafina an actress is accused of
speaking in blacks and like a black like
a black person in parentheses uh
clarifying what that means I guess on a
related note a black person that doesn't
speak like a typical black person is
accused of acting white being an Oreo
quote unquote or any other Myriad
descriptor to suggest that they're
appropriating white culture well okay
your point about the Asian actress and
we can't have heard there's been a few
examples of this Asian actresses maybe
it's hadn't happened also to
um Latino Hispanic latinx rather sorry
um actors and actresses where they've
been accused of appropriating
I think this is maybe we should narrow
it down a little bit and say this is a
charge
mostly leveled at white people
occasionally non-whip but never leveled
at black people you know a black person
is never accused of cultural
appropriation now the example you give
of well a black person is accused of
acting white no it's not the accusation
is not that you're appropriating from
white people it's supposed to be an
insult like it's it's bad it is it's an
insult you're not insulting white people
no you're it's an insult against black
people to stoop to acting like a white
person so it's a very different kind of
criticism
um
let's see King Crimson says hearing Matt
say big booty is a memory for the ages
well those these are the kind of
historic moments that you get sometimes
on the Matt Walsh show when you least
expect them
um skilled mayor says how ironic that
Matt is talking about an adult wearing a
diaper when we all know as the leader of
the SBG he too wears only a diaper well
to be clear about this as we did talk on
Friday about the adult baby diaper
loving Community as they describe
themselves
um the sweet baby Gang has no
affiliation with such a community and
I'll explain to you why the sweet baby
gang logo is an image of me as an actual
infant when I was born now it might be a
drawing but it is it it is a an accurate
artistic rendition of what I look like
at Birth I was born fully bearded and
with glasses
so
important clarification there
you know this week we're celebrating the
first anniversary of our podcast morning
wire in the short period of time that uh
they've been doing their thing it's
become one of the top news podcasts in
the world I suspect it's because morning
wire gives you only the news you need to
know in 15 minutes or less without the
manufactured outrage without the
political indoctrination or anything
else how refreshing it really is if you
haven't seen it yet you got to check it
out new episodes are available every
morning seven days a week and they give
you all the facts on the most important
stories of the day so check out
morningwired Apple podcast Spotify daily
wire Plus or wherever you listen to
podcasts also this week our Sports
podcast training companies at the
College Football Hall of Fame in Atlanta
for SEC media day hard to believe but
college football season is right around
the corner and this week the guys will
be out there getting interviews with
some of the top coaches and players in
the country so tune in to creating
companies daily Sports show on Apple
podcast Spotify daily wire Plus or
wherever you listen to podcasts and now
let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
well the New York Times used to be
considered the paper of record and uh it
still is only now it's a record of our
cultural decay the Times May no longer
you know have the same level of prestige
or credibility or any level of prestige
or credibility at all but as an
unwitting Chronicle of decadence it
still has some sort of relevance
arguably case in point the article
written by Pulitzer prize-winning
journalist Danya isawi uh isawi is are
we let's call her I think I'll go with
that yeah that sounds right Dania isawi
anyway the article is titled can't talk
I'm busy being hot a social media
movement inspired by the rapper migon
the stallion Strikes Back At The
Gatekeepers of beauty
now you of course are already expecting
that this is going to be pretty bad
given that it's in the New York Times
and it's about hotness and it mentions
migon the stallion but I assure you it's
so much worse than you anticipate it
begins
uh Edwina esteem was wearing a heavy
shapeless graduation gown it was the
color of charcoal and it reached all the
way down to her ankles and yet she had
never felt hotter as she crossed the
stage to accept her diploma she heard
the cheers from friends and family
members she was graduating from law
school and that to her was extremely hot
that was a three-year process said Miss
esteem uh SD May probably 26 who earned
her degree this spring from the shepherd
broads College of Law at uh Nova
Southeastern University and Davi there's
so many words in here that are not able
to pronounce three years of waking up
and not feeling hot for me to get to
that one day where i'm like wow this is
hot this is what's hot for me right now
she added she is one of many who are
expanding the definition of hotness
taking it Beyond its former association
with old Notions of attractiveness these
days being hot no longer pertains only
to your physical appearance but includes
how you move through the world and how
you see yourself
now if you're thinking
did this Pulitzer prize-winning
journalist really just go around
interviewing random people about times
when they felt hot and then wrote an
article about it for the New York Times
the New York Times actually published it
the answer is no she didn't just go
around interviewing them she also
watched their Instagram and Tick Tock
videos this was a full journalistic
investigation I assure you no stone was
left unturned to find all of the hot
people continuing many of those pushing
for a broader understanding of the term
are also pushing back against the idea
that you need to wait for confirmation
from someone else before feeling
Justified and calling yourself hot to
them hotness is a self-declaration and
that's that hotness is no longer just in
the eye of the beholder it's a mood it's
a Vibe Emily Sundberg a 28 year old
editor and filmmaker in Brooklyn was
eating spaghetti when she had a
realization
she was being hot there was nothing
glamorous about it it was just a solo
weeknight dinner at the kitchen counter
and Miss sunberg was wearing workout
clothes and glasses but she felt moved
to make a video of herself as she
twirled the pasta strands into a fork
and succeeded in getting most of them
all the way into her mouth as she chewed
with Kanye West jail blaring in the
background she stared into the lens with
a blank expression Miss sunberg then
posted the seven second video to
Instagram stories quote you don't have
to ask for permission to be hot online
Miss sunberg said you can take up space
and perform and create your own power
dynamics between yourself and your
audience I think being hot online is
sort of pure and debatably what social
media was originally for
that's why it was invented
with to be hot online it's true I had a
similar realization last night when I
was standing at the fridge at 11 30 P.M
opening the container with my daughter's
leftover chicken tenders which we'd
order for her at the restaurant earlier
in the evening but she hadn't touched
and then I was eating them cold along
with her side of mac and cheese which I
also ate cold and without a fork and as
I was consuming all the leftovers that
my wife specifically said she wanted to
save for lunch the following day which I
also agreed should be saved for lunch
even as I knew in my head that I would
almost certainly be eating all of them
in a gluttonous and shameful late night
binge
I too in that moment came to the
realization that I was being hot but
then I realized that I was actually just
feeling a heartburn that's why I'm
getting confused sometimes and so I took
some Tums and went to bed I only wish
that the New York Times had called me so
that I could tell them about this
experience I would have loved to share
it with them
now you may think there's no reason to
continue reading from this Times article
and you're right
but we will anyway so here's more quote
a phenomenon started by The Tick Tock
influencer Mia Lind encourages young
women to go on Four Mile walks while
remaining focused on self-affirming
thoughts in three areas what they're
grateful for their goals in life and how
they plan to accomplish them and how hot
they are miss Lynn says you may not
think of any boys or any boy drama she
said in a video that laid out the ground
rules in an interview she said that she
wanted to un gatekeep the feeling of
being hot with her hot girl walk
taking it away from male gays Arbiters
who treat daily life like some kind of
beauty pageant being hot is really
accessible more accessible than
previously thoughts at Miss Lind who
created migon the stallion as an
accreditor as an inspiration for the
walk I think there's a really big
Reclamation of the term hot the hot girl
walk has maintained its popularity since
miss Lynn posted her explanation video
which has accrued nearly 3 million
videos more than a year ago the hashtag
hot girl walk has racked up more than
280 million views now like you I am
wish I could go back in time and throw
myself off of a bridge before I'm ever
forced to hear the phrase ungate keep
the feeling of being hot
but it's too late now we've been exposed
all we can do now is
find a way to move forward and maybe try
to make some sense of all of this if we
can so here's how I make sense of it
first one of the Hallmarks of a decadent
society and this is explained quite
eloquently in the book The decadent
society which you should read if you
haven't is that it repeats itself it
runs out of new ideas and just starts
recycling old ideas over and over again
and we find this of course in Hollywood
and pop culture but we also find it in
articles like this here we have the the
stunning and revolutionary idea that the
definition of beauty should be expanded
and that confidence and self-affirmation
are important truly this is the first
time the world has ever encountered such
Notions the first time since the last
time anyway and the last time was 15
seconds before this article was
published and 15 seconds before that and
every 15 seconds for the past 30 years
at least
I mean this is the same message we've
heard on repeat for decades randomly
presented as something different and
unique all of a sudden
and because it's a Times article in the
year 2022 the issue of course has also
been arbitrarily racialized because
we're told at the end of the piece quote
Rachel Elizabeth weissler a researcher
at the University of Oregon specializing
in linguistics and black studies said
the many words and phrases that become
common in online discourse including hot
on fleek and Kiki are rooted in bypoc
and queer communities over time they
become co-opted and come to be seen as
elements of tick tock speak she said a
phenomenon she referred to as semantic
bleaching she credited me gone the
stallion as a source of the memes
promoting self-affirming messages for
young women and girls citing her 2020
song Body quote we saw Meg come out with
body during quarantine it's going to be
and she said it's going to be a hot girl
summer we're going to be happy we're
going to be confident women a lot of our
language change comes from women it
comes from black people and also from
people of color
so the word hot by the way has been used
in English to denote physical
attractiveness for at least like a
hundred years Paris Hilton made her
catchphrase 20 years ago and yet migoni
stallion as a rep is as a representative
of bypoc and queer communities quote
unquote gets credit as a source for the
concept because of a song she made two
years ago
as the author of The approximately 90
millionth pop song about hotness she is
somehow now a Pioneer she invented it
now in my opinion not to get into too
much semantics here
um if anyone should get credit as a pop
Pioneer because of self-affirming Odes
to hotness it should be the
Revolutionary musicians known as Right
Said Fred who 30 years ago produced the
playful yet poetic Anthem I'm Too Sexy
and the world has really never been the
same sense in my opinion
and yet the thing you notice about all
this
self-affirmation and supposed confidence
as always it's just how unconvincing it
is
all of these people on social media you
know declare their hotness to the world
but the Salient fact is that they're
declaring it to the world right they
they feel the need to declare it if you
were really secure and really confident
in and about yourself and your body you
wouldn't feel compelled to announce it
on social media young women don't post
selfies on Instagram or videos on Tick
Tock because they feel beautiful they do
it because they want to feel beautiful
and they're depending on the World to
tell them that they're beautiful
this is not self-affirmation but
affirmation through likes and comments
and shares which is the opposite of
self-affirmation it's the same reason
they listen to unintelligible pop songs
by semi-literate idiots like migon the
stallion
they want to be put into this kind of
trance-like state where they can believe
themselves to be cool and attractive for
three minutes at a time and that's the
primary function of modern pop music by
the way to provide mantras for
desperately insecure people
and there are a lot of Desperately
insecure people describing themselves in
ways that they want to be seen
Right This Is How They want to be seen
and need to be seen
because despite their pretensions they
depend on the world's affirmation
and spend their entire lives seeking it
and that is why finally I guess the New
York Times
before I'm told the third time is
canceled they still haven't gotten the
message so we're going to keep trying
that's going to do it for us today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day Godspeed
[Music]
the Matt wall show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover production manager Pavel vadoski
our associate producer is McKenna Waters
shows edited by Jeff Tomlin Our audio is
mixed by Mike cormina hair and makeup is
done by Cherokee heart the mat wall show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2022. a new study links the
covid vaccines to menstrual changes in
42 percent of women Joe Biden begs the
Saudi Crown Prince for oil and BLM makes
an idol out of another Thug check it out
on the Michael Knowles show
foreign